okay let's um go for the last game
affirm today's session I got an opponent
from from Germany rented 2200 something
let's play on Samish as I'm also covered
in them the default serious let's go for
the slow play near with Roxy one
like that
interesting
this looks somewhat strange
okay we'll play c5 maybe this is some
okay but cannot really believe it it to
be honest can I can I try to get
something directly here
I wonder about night a4ai deform it
plays c5 then be form if it takes I've
got them with the bishop we should be
six why just Queen takes all so good
most likely I could even capture here
okay let's let's try this of course I
spent lots of time okay threatens to
capture now with a night
hmm this wasn't a very successful idea
most likely okay out can you do so
also be difficult to develop here okay
this runs into f5 maybe but I need to
get something going here catch up a bit
on the clock at least I should i just
have played some local move ah ok
position is maybe not so bad but of
course sat down on one for one minute 48
seconds after 15 moves o mine I came the
Arab be too if you want not much I can
do about this
yeah the position actually still seems
some seems rather okay ideas should be
too with Queen f5 no this one getting to
a three
yeah what is just better I only I only
wasted lots of time always need to note
that black is playing without this
Bishop on g7 that is no it's got no play
on the on the King side yet didn't
prepare a fire for something which would
have been a good idea and this piece
configuration is also very shaky h5 yeah
okay takers okay now he retreats let's
push the route back get the B fire if it
takes my my pawns will be corrected yeah
this is already the usual kind of
cheating play on the King side after
black is positionally outplayed but it's
always dangerous of course what
hi 180 allows me to exchange Queens
elephant I'm from surprised of course
the extra point is some not worth much
but I still at the space advantage and
this should be just better for white
okay okay maybe it's just trying playing
on time it could be
yeah I wanted to exchange with Bishop g5
I need to try to be quicker here
activate the pieces of course this one
saying but not much I can do about that
we need to learn get to the pawns nida
form see id m
yeah time time time
check
yeah I will manage the time blundered
also a pawn yeah okay Apple has been
just far too much time in the opening on
the silicon night a4 move with normal
time whilst orphans are high the normal
time you just lose endgame it slowly but
surely but so of course impossible to to
make any good movie and 20 seconds at
least for me yeah this was still ok I
think and here yeah you need to be a bit
more exact here simply yeah be should be
five for instance here then 90 form very
hard from the defense e5 adds just the
crap position all the way for black what
can you do just don't don't spend three
minutes on the twelfth move or something
well thanks for watching and I'll set
you in them for further updates